[Music]  the commercials in this game are really  expensive spongebob it's just the  pregame yeah I smell a road trip that  could be my breath the spongebob movie  sponge on the run yeah that was money  well spent you wanna be friends  [Music]  Kari fits mail that  [Music]  summer the search begins friends don't  let friends to a dangerous quest  with all new faces  hello call me sage good move I made out  of sage and I am a sage so it works out  pretty well  I'm Patrick my name means toaster in  Celtic pretty sure it doesn't the most  amazing places look wouldn't worry about  us losing  [Music]  7/7 starts with an L weird movie sponge  on the run oh I love your sense of irony  Patrick thank you I love my sense of  irony too  [Music]